this talk is titled vilk Rita's package
educational resource through the use of
Mathematica software in the field of
discrete mathematics my name is Enrique
vilches Quesada i am professor catted
ratico at the school of informatics at
the National University of Costa Rica
the aim of this work lies in show the
overall operation of a package oriented
to the commercial software Mathematica
where the package volc ritas represents
an educational support to develop each
of the main topics of an discrete
mathematics course vilk ritas is the
result of a research project attached to
the school of informatics at the
National University of Costa Rica the
Ville Caritas package is designed as a
latent need in the chair of course eif
203 discrete structures for computer
science which is part of ongoing career
in information systems engineering a
novel means to address discrete
mathematics that has unfortunately
become an obstacle to student
populations with this type of courses in
addition ville Caritas is a
technological resource that can
facilitate the transformation of errant
issues in visualization and conceptual
possibilities of autonomous construction
by the student some of the benefits that
vilk ritas offers are serve sponsorship
teaching discrete mathematics courses
incorporates user friendly commence
without having a deep knowledge of
programming language Wolfram an
important aspect could eventually lead
to student teach this programming invite
tournament the package seeks to use
practical effective and agile by the
student population an essential aspect
of Bill Caritas is what the constitutes
tools for the study of real problems
internally using data analysis features
and geographical elements provided by
Mathematica villa rita is added to the
Mathematica software distributed 195
functions in the following topics
recursion recurrence relations analysis
algorithms binary relations graph theory
trees Theory machines and automatons
finite state and languages and grammars
for purposes of this talk will share two
of the most significant commands by
chapter first the Ville cretus package
rises on the issue of recursion various
commands were developed to explain to a
novice student this programming
technique suma DG for example is a
statement that sums the digits of a
natural number in the first case you run
a direct calculation in the second the
calculation is performed and the
function code is displayed to the user
in the third are the steps to perform
the calculation by the instruction and
finally in the last run it shows both
the code and the steps simultaneously
moreover the sumotori acum and automates
recursively a process to calculate any
sum for example if you want to add a
constant number as in this case the sum
varies from 1 to n minus 1 when you run
the recursive pro
graham code is displayed and the
calculation step for n equal to 20 in
the second example the sum varies from 3
to n minus 1 and n is taken equal to 10
similarly to the previous case the
recursive program evaluation and step by
step is shown for the issue of
recurrence relations will be shared
commands metod orr HL and meted oh I
metod orr HL it shows step-by-step
implementation of one of the classic
methods for solving a linear
relationship homogeneous recurrence with
constant coefficients through the use of
an equation called characteristic
equation for example to solve runs
showing step by step procedure in the
second example we have the same
situation where the initial conditions
start at zero in the third initial
conditions begin in five provided the
process in detail metod oh I shows a
linear recurrence relation of order one
their evaluations in K iterations in
ascending or descending order according
to the users choice for example in this
embodiment the recurrence relation has
this term as quotient and the second as
the in homogeneous part by deploying
five evaluations each shown with intent
to and for what would be the
generalization of the results to match
the initial condition in the second
example the same recurrence relation is
presented but in ascending order and
evaluation specifying where the initial
condition starts in three on the subject
of analysis algorithms command was
created to graphically show the concept
of asymptotic Big O notation
the graphic on a command allows the
above for example if you want to check
this asymptotic notation you could run
animation can change the value of the
constancy to realize is seen as the
graph of the absolute value of C for the
second function is sometimes above and
below the absolute value of the first
that is a theta verified asymptotic
relationship
in the second example we have the same
situation sometimes the absolute value
of the function C and by the natural
logarithm of n is above and below the
absolute value of the natural logarithm
of n factorial function
another interesting command is comp
limit to buy at the limit two functions
to derive a large asymptotic notation
they go omega or theta in example one
compliment executing a test data
notation as the limit results in a
positive constant in example two a sum
is compared with another function that
depends on the parameter J this
generates an animation in it for j less
than a seven omega notation is checked
an equal to eight in a theta notation
and verified from nine asymptotic Big O
notation a first command on the issue of
what constitutes relevant binary
relations which by a judgment written as
a string allows explicitly return the
ordered pairs that make up a relation an
example one all pairs where the
relationship criterion defines that the
greatest common divisor is equal to one
are returned in the second the criterion
is given by this equation moreover tipo
relation is a command that classifies a
binary relation reflexive symmetric anti
symmetric transitive of equivalence and
partial order the first relation is not
anti symmetric so the command justifies
showing a counter example
in the second case the relations is not
reflexive not symmetric is not anti
symmetric and not transitive is always
returning a counterexample in graph
theory vilk Rita's command an
interesting package conforms gravel
receive the edges of the graph as
ordered pairs build it in the first
example the edges of the graph are
returned by the rebbe in command and
then using the options vertices and
Derek I de Graaff is shown as a directed
graph with two isolated vertexes
in the second example a random graph is
displayed in three dimensions in the
third example the same previous graph
but where weights are assigned to each
of its edges by the pesos option is
generated
another important command thinking in
the teaching of distress algorithm it is
al district the instruction execution
algorithm provides step-by-step giving
the student the opportunity to review
what he has done in his notebook for
example
in this second case shows the result of
ditch extra-- algorithm on a graph
generated by the instruction graphic
country regions this command is able to
construct a complete graph where the
edges are the distances between each
region of a country that is specified in
this example the country is Costa Rica
finally in theory tree commands are
shared our ball our and farble s
generator ease our ball our tree
displays a tree where the user can
choose the route in the first example
the selected route is five in the second
the selected route is still five but it
has generated a directed tree with
weights on its edges and where the nodes
are shaped like a hexagon the command
farble s generator ease algorithms
executed internally with first search
search first along prim and kruskal then
the student is a tool for verification
of results
for example this graph these are the
results of all these algorithms the
conclusions of this work are presented
the following the package volc Rita's
customized a teaching effort in order to
systematize computer assisted
methodology mathematic is software in
down's a number of new commands for
teaching purposes it is a resource
available to other educational
institutions with similar courses to
include this talk share the following
website in it specifically in the
archive section is available free
download of the package volc ritas and
additional resources such as a glossary
of commands that integrates
i also want to mention the publication
of a book on the subject by the mexican
editorial alpha omega the book provides
an appropriate introduction to using the
Mathematica software to develop content
of discrete mathematics they are
cordially invited to read also I
socialize my email address for future
questions on this subject thank you very
much for the care provided okay thank
you very much